We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David p very
strange topic for today's voicemail.
Take a listen to this.
Some articles that I've seen recently about
some pockets of the left that are apparently
accusing him of not being gay enough, which
I find the slightly in nursing and in a, in
a, in a democratic field that has more diversity
than I think I've ever seen in my lifetime.
Or we have an Asian man is Jewish fan of women
of color.
Everything that you can imagine, why are we
still seeing these sorts of, these sorts of
attacks?
They're not in the mainstream support as I
can tell, but certainly, uh, areas and enclaves
of the left that sort of want to keep pushing
a very specific and focused kind of diversity.
And, um, I, you know, identity politics.
Listen, I have not seen this.
I mean, I'm not saying it doesn't exist.
I've not seen anyone say Pete Buddha judges
not gay enough, but that, that, I mean, what,
I don't even understand how that qualifies
as an argument.
Um, if someone is saying that I want to hear
about it because it's so ridiculous at its
face, but again, I think it's really important
even if it exists anecdotally.
Um, we shouldn't on the left get pulled into
going completely out of our way to refute
ideas that are barely relevant.
And this is where a lot of the, you know,
sometimes I'll appear on other shows and I'll
get asked about identity politics on the left.
I'll get asked about you, you free the free
speech, uh, um, uh, limiting leftists on college
campuses or whatever.
And I've been very critical of those things,
but I think that we need to be critical of
them in proportion to how serious of an issue
it is.
This thing of p booted judges and gay enough
if it's real, which I haven't even heard.
It's as the caller says, part of the mainstream
discussion about people who to judge.
And so our engagement with these bad ideas
and and niche ideas that are barely out there,
dumb ideas needs to be minimal because there's
no point in getting overly involved in refuting
ideas that very few people hold and that are
barely relevant within the political discussion
cause discussion.
That's been my view.
Call stuff out.
That doesn't make sense when there's an opportunity
when you see it.
Um, but the last thing I'm going to do is
start going around trying to figure out who's
saying booted judge isn't gay enough to then
focus on criticizing it.
There's much bigger ideas to talk about and
way bigger fish to fry.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We'll talk about the White House asking the
navy to hide a warship named after late Senator
John Mccain Kane
and much more get instant access to the bonus
show by becoming a member@joinhackman.com.
I'll speak to you though